oh the boat trip was going to take them
to freedom they had fled violence
dictatorship forced labor
they'd crossed the Sahara Desert they'd
seen others die on the way those who
could phone their loved ones to tell
them they'd set out tomorrow across the
sea from Libya to Italy but those calls
were the last that's been heard of that
one there's no evidence the voter action
no record of them arriving in Italy no
documentation of them landing anywhere
else the boat and then nearly 250 people
on it
just vanished like most on the boat 24
year old Seguin and her baby were from
Eritrea one of the world's most
repressive States Sagan's husband Yavin
escaped a military camp in 2007 ending
across the border in the Sudanese
capital Khartoum Seguin joined him in
2009 they married and had two daughters
but still they sought a better life
and plotted another escape Seguin and
the baby would go first hoping to
eventually reach Norway the last time he
had heard from his wife she called him
to say the boat was set to leave when he
heard nothing you have to call the
smuggler who told him his family had
arrived in Italy yeah that waited but no
word other families also worried the
refugee ships were commonly sinking one
of this size would have left evidence
corpses float or wash ashore pieces of
the boat drift in the water did the boat
ever leave where did the passengers go
it's a mystery
but we have clues a man claiming to be a
prison guard called one family
he claimed the group was held in a
Tunisian jail there are other theories
perhaps they were captured or sold into
slavery where is the ghost boat a team
of international journalists are trying
to find out they need your help each
clue will be examined in an episode the
hope is together the audience can
investigate share tips and help crack
the case follow the story on medium
it cannot continue like this we cannot
accept that hundreds of people die when
trying to cross the sea to Europe